hello uh my name is Leah and I want to
talk to you about prompt engineering 101
get introduction to longchain and before
I talk about Lang chain I want to say
one word I'm a bit worried that me
wearing this mask might have a vector
experience it might be unusual for some
people
I have colleagues who rely on lip
reading and they told me this mask helps
them and it helps them but also moves
when I laugh so for the first five
minutes it might feel weird but be
patient in five minutes you'll be used
to it just bear with me okay so let's
talk about Lang chain
so this is the agenda of my talk first
I'll give a general overview why there's
so much hype about long chain jail
introduction to the llm ecosystem
after that I'll deep dive into one chord
example which I played with
then I will talk about evaluating models
created with long chain and finally I'll
talk about briefly the future of this
Library
so why there's so much hype around long
chain
this library is six months old and it's
already raised 10 million as a seed
investment this month and this is the
star graph you know getting from 0 to 25
000 stars in six months that's pretty
cool like it reminds about the early
days of hugging face or razza or similar
open source success stories
and I would like to explain why is there
so much hype about it in my opinion
so life before the invention of fire was
very hard
and building models before invention of
a lamb was hard I had to hire database
manager to create my data warehouse and
I had to hire an email engineer to build
my models
then I had to label data with some
experts
and maybe
it will take a month for my ml engineer
to build the model and I have to hire ml
apps ml Ops person to serve it and
finally I have some kind of prototype
which I could show to potential you know
20 users
that's how it was before
and now is this Gutenberg moment the
invention of the printing press you know
this your LinkedIn feed is full of this
stuff you know how like now in this post
llm world and everything is super easy
and nowadays you just call openai okay
here AI or some other API
write a bit of natural language text
maybe tune it a little bit connect your
own corporate documents or give it the
context of your mobile application and
you get to a prototype
so you already have something you can
play with
yes it's flimsy but it's already a
prototype
and this is the magic this is why your
LinkedIn feed is full of this stuff and
you play with it and it kind of breaks
that's when it gets hard we actually to
make it not break you actually have to
label data just like in the old times
you actually have to retrain your model
just like you know six months ago you
have to and then you get to V2
and then you have to you get more users
and you need to get all this continuous
user feedback every time you say open AI
thumbs up or thumbs down or to your
GitHub co-pilot the product improves for
that company and for everybody and you
have to have some way to do
reinforcement learning on this data
so the all times are hard like rolling a
rock up up the mountain
you know collecting data hiring ml
labeling data building the model serving
the model just to get to the Prototype
that was hard from the very beginning
and after the invention of fire and the
printing press and llms it's a bike ride
you know there's a this icon of the bike
for something which is easy
to get to your V1 which is a flimsy
prototype it's very easy
and after that live gets hard
so the first orange part you can even
now do in typescript if you want like
you don't even need to know python to do
machine learning prototype in 2023 but
don't worry there's still jobs in this
V2 in the green Parts on the bottom
labeling data retaining new models
getting continuous user feedback there's
still jobs for everybody who's in Python
data science
and just this bar became easier
um
there's more philosophy and after that
we'll move to code
so there's a saying that during a gold
rush cell shovels
what does it mean
if there's a valley and suddenly like
three or four people find gold in that
Valley
this first people they get rich you know
the prices of gold are high you know
this is what will happen if you started
a generative music startup five years
ago or generative text two years ago
there's a lot of people who benefit a
lot from that people who first got there
and what's the second stage of the Gold
Rush is millions of people coming to the
valley everybody gets a small plot and
starts digging
and maybe they find gold maybe not the
prices of gold are getting lower so it's
not so clear however everybody who has a
plot needs a shovel
and it has to be a shovel like it has to
be something which anybody can use
and Lang chain is slowly becoming this
kind of shovel
I'm shovel in a good sense it's not like
a bad thing like a good shovel is good
much better than my hands
you know just something that anybody can
pick up in python or in JavaScript and
create the first prototype
um yeah so that's how there's my
connection for the hype around
long chain that it is a shovel during a
gold rush
and of course if you want to move to V2
you need to find an excavator and
excavator driver like most of us in this
room are drivers of these excavators
and then we need to label data fine tune
it get it to V2 make reinforcement
learning to be free
and nv3 it actually becomes golden
because that's hard to reproduce if you
want it's just a lamb on the prompt
anybody can do this like there's enough
there's no way to defense my business if
my business relies on just one prompt
however if I invested all this stuff in
my excrete infrastructure that becomes a
real business model
and that's where the gold is actually in
in V3
so let's move to a code example there's
a notebook relating to this talk if you
want to look at it
um
yeah and of course the live demo Gods
um they think there'll Miss some errors
if you look at the repo now but in an
hour it will be better of course like
you can't rely on open AI API so the
example that I decided to play with
is the question
when is the python D in Period of
brilliant 2013 2023 conference
and how many days are between that date
and today
and I allowed the model to use internet
and the python Rebel
okay so this is the code extract on the
left
it says tools
load tools the API for search for search
engine and then a llm map which is a
thing that takes in text and creates
python code to answer math questions
and I create an agent my agent
initialize agent with the tools in my
llm
the kind of agent is called zero shot
react description which is links to
their react library or direct paper
there's a paper called react published
by a group of researchers
and Lang chain did what open source is
supposed to do they took this academic
code and made it into nice python with
you know types and classes something
which you could actually want to use
that's one of the great things that made
Lang chain become so popular is
re-implementation of this react paper
and here I'm using tools and agents so
those are the fundamental concepts of
long chain difference between tool and
agent tool is something deterministic
every time I call it I get the same
result
for example python repel I type you know
print hello world prints hello world
every time
or sending an email same thing happens
and it's very easy to actually add new
tools to llm I just tell to the prompt
hello llam this is a calculator
calculator it's useful for when you need
to answer questions about math
and it just starts using calculator for
that that's pretty awesome
um
their new thing is the agent
and agents are non-deterministic they
make their own decisions
they it's not clear what's going to
happen every time you call it they have
agency
autonomy
like every time I search Google the
results might change this is not a very
good example of an agent but the agent
that you know tells me when do I have
time in my schedule or when should I
call my mother next time you know it
decides it for me and I Outsource some
of my decision power to that all the
important decision that you have in your
life
and there's this new trend of companies
called agents as a service a a a s
so like if you want to raise more money
just say you're doing agent as a service
and you'll do better
um cool so let's see how well does this
thing work
so the answer that I got from this piece
of code
so python Gene Pi data Berlin 2023
conference is on 16th of January 12 noon
City and they're 45 000 days between
that date and today
like sounds very logical I put into
Google python D and pilated Berlin 2023
date the first answer I get is 16th of
January noon CET
just goes to this page and gets it
that's how Google parse this page
and okay I can blame it on Google that's
why it doesn't work
but why is it 45 000 days like
and I mean we all use daytime Library
many times in the daytime Library if you
say 16th of January and don't specify
any year what do you get
1900 exactly so between 1900 and today
it's 45 000 days
so it's very nice answer almost right
but no cigar
and this is like V 0.5 maybe it's not
quite V1
but it's like getting there and the
question is how hard is it to get from
this to V1 that's what Lang chain
promises me to do to to tune this
retrieval and you know prompt
engineering let's see what's happening
there
so let's look under the hood this is a
tracing of the calls which are made to
open AI
I'll show the interactive UI in a second
so you can see there are many steps you
know they are grouped together as a tree
so you have the big search agent demo is
the big root of the tree it shows it
cost me three cents to do this in
complicated research that's how much
money I paid to open IA
um there's a ancient executor the next
Source there's a call to the open II API
asking him to answer the question
then I call a search engine API and I go
back to open AI I call this I can do the
Google search again
then I go back to open AI again
then I generate some python code again
using openai
and finally I have get to the final
answer in the last thing so there are
many calls in here
and
it's nice to look under the hood what is
happening
so yeah this is more interactive version
of this viewer
so let's start with the main prompt
answer the following questions as best
as you can you have access to the
following tools search
and calculator and I describe briefly
what they are
and I
say which former to talk to me because
actually parse the outputs that come
into me you can ask it to talk to you in
text you can ask to talk to you in Json
and you can use like pedantic to parse
output of llm for example if you want to
of course it will fail because it's a
lot of them sometimes
and the question I'm asking it
when is the conference how many days are
between the date and today
and the output is I need to find the
date of the conference calculate the
number of dates between the data today
okay intelligent thing to say action
surge
and search for this by continued potato
Berlin 2023
so we go to the search
and this is just a simple API that
returns me the first thing on Google
and the first thing on Google is like we
aim to be an accessible Community Driven
okay
[Music]
um
I need to look at a more specific result
I need to search for date
logical yeah
I don't know let me
do the live demonet yeah this is the
output in the end
sounds pretty reasonable to me
so let's see what happens to the search
for the date we get 16th of January noon
that's that's what Google decided is the
date of the conference okay
so now we move to the next step I need
to calculate the number of days between
this date and today call my friendly
calculator and this is the input to the
calculator
cool how does it work
translate a math problem into python
code
this is the example prompt that I give
it to
and it's a few short learning so I have
actually some examples in here which I
give it one example
what is this thing
let's see what kind of code it generated
so this is a python code generated
I would probably write the same actually
and make the same mistake of daytime as
it's doing
and yeah so I can relate
ah
and the number you get is 45
000 and the final thing is yeah this is
the final answer
like it says I now know the final answer
final answer is this
and this is parsed by Lang chain under
the hood
and
um yeah given to me as the final answer
here
um
this kind of interactive tracing is very
nice like at least I can see where I
spend my money how many calls I made in
there
however like
I tried to improve based on this
feedback and I couldn't get there
like because prompt engineering is quite
tricky it's not like you know tuning
with gradient descent it's like very
non-linear you change one little thing
and then the answer changes a lot
and you know for V1 it's probably okay
but I wouldn't build like the whole
product based on this right now
so what I showed you so far if I just
give it the tools of Google and python
math I get wrong conference date but
correct today's date at least I get
correct today's date
then I crawled the website of pycon De
and I gave it as a tool just answer
questions about python de using this
index to link chain and managed to find
correct conference data I was very
impressed
however today's date just forgot what it
is
like it just gave me something day like
you know a year ago for some strange
reason or like a year and a half ago
even and I don't know why
just everything was the same just an
extra tool added and then suddenly lost
the ability to find out today's date
um so I thought okay maybe I'll give it
another tool to be better dates so I
gave it a python way to find out today's
date
and it's today's date was correct but
the conference dated stopped doing for
some reason that thing fell through
maybe it needs to break down tasks into
smaller things so I gave it to Baby IGI
like a to-do list generator
and that thing just went on some kind of
tangent talking about conference food
and like having to book a venue that was
really annoying
so I couldn't really get it to work so
easily but that was fun
and there I felt the rush I felt the
gold rush you know the more the Gold
Rush experience is definitely there not
sure about the product but this is this
is how far I have gotten
um let me talk about the evaluation
it's very nice to evaluate results with
GPT
and gpt4 is almost as good as this
generic
person whom you pay you know 20 an hour
on mechanical term to do like generic
questions like how good is the sum
already
you know Does this answer this question
correctly or not about this short piece
of text this kind of generic questions
which require just knowledge of English
or German
they are pretty much done by gpt4
yeah there's no more boring automation
however there's a lot of expert
annotation left to do for people you
know if you're a radiologist or a lawyer
it will be much easier for you to give
feedback
um with this kind of fast evaluation
um
and they were talks about this at this
conference
so I try I asked
uh uh GPT to evaluate its own answers
and it's quite easy to do with blank
chain
so
and I said the UI teacher grading a quiz
the correct answer is 17 of April and
the are minus two days that's how I
think that minus two days from start of
the conference maybe it's minus three
like whatever
um that's the correct answer
and this is the answer from a student
give it a grade and explain why it's
wrong and here's explanation at the
bottom it says grade is zero
out of 10.
so first check the date of the
conference aha your data is wrong
and then check the number of days
between the conference and today
that is quite nice
it's strange that GPT is good at grading
if you say it like graded from 0 to 10
that's fine but if you ask it like which
one answer is better it always chooses
the first one
it has this like recency bias just like
the same way if you ask me like which
one do I want to buy I always take the
one closest to me so it's very kind of
human bias behavior of this but grading
just great on a scale that works quite
well
um
cool
the future of long chain
so the is a parallel package to python
line chain called langchain.js
and it allows front-end devs to build ml
product we want
and don't worry you still need python
for v2 and V3 I played with this Thai
typescript library to integrate it with
zoom SDK and when I do like some live
sessions with clients it somehow gives
me advice what they saying and what I
should say to them it's kind of fun
yeah and I don't know any typescript of
course like copilot told me how to do
this
um there is production support
by Lang chain it's a new library I'm not
sure if I would put into production the
other more experienced libraries for
question answering which are here at
this conference been around for a couple
of years I would rather use them in line
chain but you can pay them for
production support if you want and of
course they'll be implementing papers
like every academic paper that comes out
has very nice code in long chain
um that's like that team is really good
at that
um making these papers much more
accessible and tinkerable that way
and of course there'll be more agents
more document readers retrievals inputs
formats you can send it Json you can
output it Json and do the type checking
on that
and retry if it's wrong
um
[Music]
let me talk more about the
go back to the evaluation there's a very
nice package called Auto evaluator
so if you have a collection of documents
and you want to answer questions about
it and they are more than the
context window of you know 10 pages as
we have now I mean it will be 50 pages
soon but you cannot put more than that
so if you have you know 200 pages in
your corporate
document store and you want to ask
questions about it you need to use
something long chain is something you
can use for that
and there are many parameters you can
tune there and it's not clear which ones
are better
and there this package called Auto
evaluator which creates the exam for
your model with correct answers then
also runs that exam
with the model and then grades how good
it is at answering that so it basically
generates correct questions to your
knowledge base and with correct answers
and then
evaluates the whole thing by itself so
you don't really need to annotate
anything you already know how good is
your evaluation your QA tool at your
knowledge base
um yeah have a look at that for a bit
cool so yeah this is my final slide
I run this Meetup where we do Ensemble
programming and tdd it's called Berlin
data Crafters so like next week it's
online and we will talk more about
blockchain and trying to learn it
together with TTD which will be
interesting to see how that works
uh thank you
[Applause]
wow that was well within time or on time
so we have a couple of questions on the
slider so I'll go through each of them
can you talk about
can you talk about the origins of Lang
chain and why do you think it gained so
many users quickly
yep
[Music]
um
so
I I it's it was one of the few packages
which are using llms like back in
October
um and I think what really helped it is
implementing this react paper which is
how to introduce tools to our llm and
this is basically this prompt what I'm
showing you here and you can add any
kind of tools to it that you want search
calculator you know corporate store
document index anything like this
and taking it from research code into
nice python code that's I think that
made it very popular
yeah
but it's a bit surprising like for
example for question answering if I
Google question answering of llm I find
Lang chain instead of haystack which is
like a small bird which was a Berlin
like more established three-year-old
company so I don't know why
the second one would be what are your
views on tools like prompt perfect for
prompt optimization yeah from perfect is
cool and
like
it gives you ideas but it's not like
guaranteed to work
so it's from perfect is the way to use
um like llm to optimize your prompt but
it's like for me it's when I'm stuck it
gives me some ideas but then
I still have to try them it doesn't
solve it completely for me
anymore uh yeah several actually which
version of GPT did you use for your
experiments 3.5 turbo or four this is a
text DaVinci free
that does the easiest one that comes
with long chain yeah the default one
that long chain uses
could you have improved the result in
your example if you added check if the
result you gave gives a plausible number
of days
ah
yeah
like that kind of automatic engraving
like is it a plausible result or not
that would be
quite nice but I haven't tried this
formulation plausible
um
yeah but I haven't actually yeah I don't
know if if GPT knows what plausible is
in its own world
so the next question would be what
performance metric should I code for my
agent as a service product
yeah like performance metrics you mean
like latency or
you know like
how good it is
exactly so how um how good am I at
answering
um
for question answering like clear
metrics like we've been around for a
while and you can grade it like this
depends on your problem like how how
what what is your problem what do you
care about it's
um it's a bit like evaluating any kind
of machine learning model the best
metrics that the user facing metrics
except this one is a non-deterministic
the next one what framework do you
recommend for production use
depending on your problem yeah for Q a I
would use
Haystack even though yeah I don't work
for them I don't work for long chain
either it's more like last week we had a
bunch of people cancel the talks and we
in programming committee decided to give
our own talks so I got a chance to talk
about something I enjoyed tinkering with
more oh yeah
oh yeah so are you using gpt4 for that
reason are you paying for request
for what are you paying for your
requests gpt4 I mean I'm paying for my
request to DaVinci like you see there's
like three cents here that's how much
I'm paying I I have access to GPT for
chat but I don't have access to gpt4 IPI
like the 8000 token thing I don't have
it and I don't know anybody has 32 000.
does anybody have access to 32 000 gpt4
here
okay no no time travelers
before we take more questions he's the
second speaker Louis Fernando Alvarez
here
okay then we could cut short last two
questions and
so is there something long chained as
well
like this agent thing like that's really
does it pretty well better than anybody
else like if you say it you know do this
task as best as you can that's what it
does really well the whole age intake
agent thing if you want to talk for like
notion and put it into some kind of
weird database they're already loaders
for that like it has like a hundred
different loaders for different
documents and output formats so yeah
this diversity is definitely there the
community is gigantic like if you come
to a webinar long chain there's like 3
000 people there
so this would be the last question
how you run the traces UI interface uh
yeah I see the notebook like the this
link in this repo there's a way to run
it there it's a nice visualizer it's not
the default visualizer blockchain
somebody else created it with this ice
Library interactive composition Explorer
yeah but I really I really like it more
than the default
um tracer
cool thank you so it seems like
[Applause]